seit zwei jahren verlangt die politik
von den jüngsten die größten
einschränkungen masken pflicht
permanentes lüften ständiges testen zum
schutz der erwachsenen da circa drei
millionen über 60 noch nicht geimpft
sein bleiben die maßnahmen so der
oberste gesundheitsschutz unser ziel ist
es durch diese welle durch zu kommen
dass wir dann zurückblicken könne nur
sagen
in deutschland sind sehr wenige ältere
menschen in dieser schweren omikron
welle loch gestorben statt gezielt die
risikogruppen zu schützen müssen kinder
und schüler weiter opfer bringen obwohl
sie selbst selten schwer erkranken
kritiker fordern einen strategiewechsel
die drei millionen die ihn auch nach wie
vor mein sieg m ungeimpft durch diese
krise hindurch tragen die verantwortung
für sich selbst und können sie nicht
delegieren an die kinder das ist eine
hypothek da sagen uns ja nun alle dass
diese hypothek für die kinder zwei jahre
lang darunter zu leiden
zumindestens hoffentlich nicht
irreparabel aber zumindest langjährige
schäden machen
schulen sind keine pandemie treiber fand
das robert koch institut heraus aber im
moment gefühlt hotspot die
infektionszahlen teilt dreimal so hoch
wie in der restlichen bevölkerung
einigen macht das angst auch wenn
infiziert nicht gleich krank bedeutet
faktisch werden immer mehr kinder nach
hause geschickt wir haben in berlin fünf
prozent aller schüler in dieses
infiziert sind wir haben noch mal sechs
oder sieben prozent die sich in
quarantäne befinden das heißt ein
beträchtlicher teil der schülerschaft
befindet sich sogar schon im lock down
die schulen sind quasi indirekt
geschlossen obwohl weiterhin propagiert
wird dass die schulen offen werden dass
die schon sicher werden landauf landab
unterschiedliche quarantäne regeln in
manchen bundesländern entscheiden lehrer
wer kommen darf und wer nicht im land
berlin hat die politik die verantwortung
einfach an die eltern übertragen wir
sehen dass wir auch eltern haben die
sich sorgen und die gerne diese
entscheidung ob sie ihr kind in die
schule schicken oder nicht auch selbst
treffen möchten das land berlin hebt auf
wunsch von eltern die präsenzpflicht auf
besonders pikant daran ein anspruch auf
distanz unterricht besteht nicht die
politik duckt sich weg das recht auf
bildung der pandemie bekämpfung geopfert
schadensbegrenzung ich halte das nicht
für den richtigen weg weder den schulen
die entscheidungen darüber zu zu
überlassen ob sie in distanz oder in den
präsenzunterricht gehen noch den eltern
eine rückkehr zur normalität fordern
immer mehr eltern initiativen der fokus
auf die kinder in der pandemie nützte
ihnen kaum und führe zu ganz anderen
schäden wenn wir jeden tag testen
vermitteln wir den kindern das gefühl
sie sind irgendwie gefährlich und
anstecken das macht psychischem auf was
wir haben jetzt eine anstieg der der
suizidversuche bei kindern jugendlichen
die honorare in gruppen können sich
jetzt alle impfen und postern und fb2
masken tragen und haben jede menge
schutzmaßnahmen individuell zur
verfügung die sie nutzen können wenn sie
das möchten dementsprechend gibt es
keinen grund mehr die schüler in ihrem
alltag einzuschränken der
bundesgesundheitsminister bleibt dabei
auch kinder müssen helfen drei millionen
ungeimpfte über 60 zu schützen
kontrollieren dazu dass sie möglichst
schnell durch die welle durch kommen das
ist das was wir für die kinder tun
können gesundheitsschutz mit
nebenwirkungen die jüngsten fühlen sich
von der politik übersehen warten immer
noch auf mehr unterstützung und eine
exit strategie